superhero movies have dominated the
box-office but it's rare for them to be
honored with nominations in the major
Academy Awards categories let alone the
biggest one of all with that in mind
here's a look at how Black Panther made
history and how this marks a turning
point for the Oscars it's never gets
hard
[Music]
we've all become accustomed to marvel's
refusal to settle for superficial
storylines in their films there's no
shortage of modern action movies that
end up feeling like little more than an
excuse to unload a pile of cash on CGI
and special effects the MCU on the other
hand has figured out how to combine
large scale effects with meaningful
plots deep drama and complex characters
nowhere is this more apparent than at
Black Panther Black Panthers on-screen
arc started in Captain America Civil War
which led to the solo film beginning
with T'Challa already having taken up
the mantle of the hero of Wakanda Black
Panther was still essentially an origin
story marking the true beginning of the
king of Wakanda story as the story
unfolded it didn't skimp on the drama
either continuing to evolve to Chavez
persona as he struggled with his past
revelations regarding his father and the
repercussions of long-held family
secrets from personal storylines to the
introduction of Wakanda the film's story
was masterfully told and the film's
nominations will only pave the way for
future superhero films of the same
caliber to earn the Academy's attention
even the best scripts can often feel
pointless if they aren't brought to life
by quality acting and black panther
knocked this one out of the park in
spades front and center of course we
have the lovable yet tough chadwick
boseman who is able to depict T'Challa
as a character with a fierceness of
resolve but along with that he also
brought a depth of feeling understanding
and complexity that helped elevate the
entire movie of course Bozeman
supporting cast was also filled with
talented actors modern cinema staples
like Andy Serkis who played returning
villain Ulysses Klaw
you mean God we just doesn't tell anyone
or not the film also featured
up-and-coming stars like Leticia Wright
who delivered a memorable performances
two challahs sister Sheree and then
there's Michael B Jordan who's kill
monger isn't just impressive he's
heart-wrenching
in just over two hours Jordan managed to
create a personality that rivals the
multi movie character arc of Loki and
the dramatic complexity of Thanos few
would argue that the movie's long list
of quality performances was another
crucial factor that launched the film
into the academy's balance while acting
directing and storytelling are all
aspects of the film that weren't
specifically honored by the Academy
Awards a quick glance at the various
nominations continues to reveal just how
thoroughly the movie left its impact two
of the nominations came for sound
editing and sound mixing and it racked
up two more for Original Score and
original song the quartet speaks for
itself the audible experience of black
panther from the sound effects to the
music was superbly executed
[Applause]
two more nominations were landed in the
categories of production design and
costume design both of which speak to
the film's impressive array of scenery
and clothing all of these recognitions
are neatly wrapped up with the Best
Picture nomination which puts a bow on
one of the most accomplished chapters in
the MCU while arguments can be made for
previous Marvel films that might have
been the first to receive the honor of a
Best Picture nomination there's no
question that Black Panther deserved the
nod on its own merits it's hard to
believe that heading into the 2019 Oscar
ceremony the DC EU has won more Oscars
than the MCU by a whopping score of 1 to
0 with that lone win coming in the form
of makeup and hair styling for
everyone's favorite Oscar winner Suicide
Squad and but while the two comic
universes have certainly received the
short end of the stick there have been a
handful of awards over the decades given
to several superhero classics perhaps
the nearest and dearest to the heart of
Marvel fans was spider-man 2 which won
an award for its visual effects several
years before Suicide Squad comic fans
were also thrilled to see The Dark
Knight when two Academy Awards won for
editing and won for Best Supporting
Actor and honored posthumously given to
Heath Ledger for his performance as the
Joker however while the two awards were
in many ways a seminal moment for the
superhero genre in the Academy's history
perhaps the greatest impact came from
the fact that the film wasn't nominated
for Best Picture the perceived injustice
became a rallying point for comic fans
in many ways helping pave the way for
the achievement that black panther
finally realized it's this issue over
Best Picture nominations that has stuck
in the craw of so many comics fans over
the years while there is at least a
semi-reasonable track record of
nominations and wins for technical
categories like makeup sound editing and
special effects there has always been a
serious lack of attention for comic-book
adaptations in the Best Picture category
while films like The Dark Knight began
to shift the conversation from an if to
more of a when the success of other
genres should be taken into account when
tracing the paths leading to Black
Panthers historic success for example it
was considered outlandish when the
classic animated film
Beauty and the Beast was nominated for
Best Picture in the early 90s and yet
since then we've seen films like up and
Toy Story 3 follow in its footsteps
proving that the premise isn't as
important as the part that holds it up
then there's the fantasy epic Lord of
the Rings Return of the King which
dominated the 76th Academy Awards with a
clean sweep
winning all 11 of the Oscars it was
nominated for while comics trailblazers
have done their part over time the
little victories along the way like the
success of Peter Jackson's monumental
trilogy of Tolkien adaptations have
certainly helped reshape the landscape
setting the stage for the Best Picture
nomination that finally took superhero
movies to the next level of acclaim
after all let's not forget that 2018 s
Best Picture winner was a movie about a
fish god why not one about a guy who
dresses like a cat another factor behind
the gradual acceptance of comic book and
superhero based movies comes from a
certain level of cinematic maturation
that has taken place over the years it's
safe to say that past superhero films
have been well kind of cheesy
the MCU has been a major factor in
pushing the genre to a more mature level
after a long incubation period that saw
characters like Tony Stark Thor and
Captain America finding their stride the
modern concept of the superhero movie
has certainly come a long way as the MCU
has evolved it's played on a bigger
canvas and grasp that loftier ambitions
as well as more complex character arcs
this has naturally pushed the end
product to higher levels while that
initial growth culminated with Black
Panthers recognition by the Academy it's
only a matter of time before we see even
more mature more accomplished superhero
films and see more of them reach the
Oscars podium there are many reasons
black panther broke through the barrier
of acceptance with the world's most
prestigious award ceremony the
combination of timing and quality has
launched director Ryan Coogler creation
into the spotlight as advised for
recognition that has been denied to so
many worthy superhero films before the
most exciting part of 2019 s Academy
Awards however is what it might lead to
next the final acceptance of superhero
movies as award worthy Entertainment has
further opened the doors for serious
filmmakers and artists to genuinely
invest themselves into their comics to
screen adaptations not only in hopes of
garnering the adulation of the fans but
of possibly winning a nice shiny Oscar
while they're at it
there's only one thing to say about that
kind of future check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you